Beyonce is still in hiding and skipped
out on the BT Awards the internet cannot
get over how hot Steve Carell is plus
the Bellas are back and only we've got
the acha
awesome set secrets from pitch perfect
three and I'm really going to refrain
from being acha awkward and sing man
that really lasted 2.5 seconds hi
friends this is the daily Denny I missed
you guys over the weekend how you
holding up I was in New York City this
weekend chatting with the cast of
spider-man homecoming I'll have that for
you guys later this week you're in for a
treat let me tell you but first we need
to get you caught up on the stories
flooding our feet today Beyonce was a
big winner at last night's BT Awards
taking home five trophies including best
female R&B pop artist and best album for
lemonade and yes she's still racking up
awards for that masterpiece folks
sadly Queen B did not make it she of
course has some babies to take care of
right now
but we still have not gotten any social
media update from B since she and jay-z
welcomed the twins so where are they
well the Daily Mail calm is reporting
that they have not actually gone to
their real home just yet they are in a
rented Malibu mansion after spending
about a week in the hospital but this is
not some air B&B on the coast get this
the luxurious rental includes 14
bathrooms 10 bedrooms and a 25-foot
infinity pool I'm not sure how the
babies will get to enjoy those amenities
but Bloo you must be living your best
life right now Plus mom and dad you
literally have a room for each of your
Grammys have you summoned to the Carters
alright meanwhile back over at the
Beatty Awards Beezus sister Solange
scored a top honor as did Chancellor
rapper and Bruno Mars who kicked off the
night with in epic performance proving
yet again he is one of music's best show
men still there was another pint-sized
dude nearly stole the show I'm talking
about DJ Khaled son Asad the father-son
duo posed on the red carpet and let me
tell you something this 8 month old is
eating up the limelight Aditi's Kevin
Frazier found out I noticed is he walked
down the car but he is just enjoying and
soaking up every single moment of the
yeah you know me and mommy always keep
them around greatness we always give
them joy we always give them happiness
we always give them love and you know
the way I was lay my family brought me
around what they do you're saying and
I'm flinging them out what me and
mommy's you're right yes boy how much
fun is it to have and tell me about this
suit how do you get this suit made and
who made that suit Gucci made it on
mommy took him to the Gucci store and
got Gucci to tear them up and got him a
custom Gucci apparently gucci mane was
rockin the same Gucci suit as Assad
twinning all right someone who's also
looking sharp this past weekend steve
carell he recently took a giant leap
into Anderson Cooper territory and the
internet is going bananas the 54 year
old was across the pond promoting
Despicable Me 3 and London and looking
100 that's the photo right there that
first got our attention and we're one
Twitter user perfectly summed up our
newfound Thurs she tweeted honestly take
your Gosling and your zayn malik's and
give me 2017 Steve Carell and thankfully
for us he looked just as dashing at the
LA premiere of the movie where are Carly
still got his reaction to all the love
for his full-blown great people are
digging what they call the Silver Fox
look you're a really deep you damn Steve
Carell makes us not gray hair I am so
sick of people looking at me for my
physical attributes they are it's just
genetic something I could do nothing
will prepare you for these hot photos of
speed Corral what is your reaction to
all this remember Aurra yes I'm busting
this pride
that's very nice your wife thinks if she
sees that he's not and back off she know
she goes through you know icy hot and
that's all that matters okay hide yo
kids hide your wives I'm talking to you
Clooney Carell is coming for your spot
as the most handsome silver fox in
Hollywood so watch your back and while
we wait for Clooney's comeback the
Bellas are back in a new trailer for
pitch perfect 3 the movie doesn't hit
theaters until Christmas time as you can
tell from this teaser is about to be lit
my pocket finished
I love you awesome nerds
try to have some dignity
yeah well we don't do anything with
dignity okay in the movie the Bellas
reunited for a USO tour of Europe and
rebel Wilson told us that fans should
get ready for a very different pitch
perfect because apparently there is a
ton of action in this one
I thought cuffs was pretty action-packed
in that first one but one thing that
hasn't changed the girls bond on and off
the screen we have such a fun time that
when we need that was our last day of
all filming together which yeah all the
girls were crying because we don't know
we don't know what the future will be
after the third movie and yes so we'll
see clearly when pitch-perfect three
ended they did not want it to be over
but all good things must come to an end
including today's daily Deni yes I'm so
good at the transitions today are you
guys thank you so much for watching be
sure to head over each online.com for
the full pitch perfect 3 trailer and hit
subscribe on ETA youtube channel for
more daily Deni and until tomorrow time
to dance my way out of here
bye